Arthur's gonna start us off Chris in
Illinois hi Martha welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave thank you for
taking my phone call sure how can we
help
well I just started listening to you I'm
a few months ago and I actually filed
for chapter 13 bankruptcy and August and
I was just looking for some guidance as
to like how I should proceed
you know I've been able to save a
thousand dollars but I can't do the of
that snowball right now because I'm
obviously in bankruptcy but so like what
would be your um you're in space for me
I guess how to go for it
show you by yourself you're single okay
the two of you alright
and what's your household income so last
year we made 56 combined
okay and how much debt did you file on
in the chapter 13 it was about I'm sorry
I want to say was close to 50 I don't
have some people with me what was it
that scared you or pushed you to the
point that you went and filed well I
started when we started doing our budget
but we realized that we were about a
thousand dollars in the read every time
so we were making or we were spending
more money than we were making and we
had a lot of personal loans and they
were like I'm just the payments were
coming out of our paycheck every every
two weeks so it was just very
overwhelming and we we just couldn't do
it
okay out of fifty thousand what were
your big payments so yes personal
no no but what would give me your
biggest payment what was the biggest
payment that was driving you nuts
fine sure again they were they were the
personal loans combined just those but
loans were the ones that were tell how
much as how much of the fifty thousand
her personal loans it was about probably
like ten grand it wasn't that much but
the interest rate was much was your car
payment
our car payment was 325 what about the
other one we only had one how much your
house plan on we rent so it was 800
what's the student loans we don't have
any which collectors were driving you
crazy we weren't at that point yet so
Martha did you all have credit cards we
did okay so you had I believe before I'm
sorry before we filed all our payments
were were up to date we weren't behind
but we just it didn't matter how much my
husband drives her over so it didn't
matter how many hours he put in like
every time we would go to make our
payments we would end up negative yeah
and so you got the personal loans for
what what were you doing with the money
from the personal loans well we thought
that we can consolidate some of the
credit cards or other smaller loan yeah
and so that what you're feeling now is
the opposite of what we teach with the
debt snowball will you leave them
individually you put all of these in
together and you felt overwhelmed and a
large interest rate and a large payment
right and so the the where you go from
here right now is I want you to hear me
where you are right now it doesn't have
to be where you end up unless you all
change your habits see you got to
understand that that debt is not your
friend young lady the personal loans and
the credit card so not your friend it's
a friend of me it's a thing you thought
was your friend that it's your enemy and
it takes from you so one of the things
to do is to really dig in and plug in to
financial peace and learn
properly budget and stay allergic to
debt because if not Martha what I've
seen people do as a financial coach
people will end up going back into the
same habits that got them there so
here's what here's what we're talking
about the numbers you're giving us I
keep my head keeps going sideways
because I can't find the hole in the
math with what you've given me unless
the $10,000 is a ridiculous interest
rate in the short term meaning you're
paying $1,000 a month out on that
because you should have been able to pay
the payments that you're doing I think
you just got overwhelmed disorganized
and scared which there's it's not a sin
but I was trying to figure out what
happened that forced you into there it
wasn't somebody coming after you it was
the sense of no traction so we're gonna
put you in financial peace with your
husband for a year
okay I'm gonna pay for it for a year I
want you to stay in there what you do
the budget every month now how do you
get out of a chapter 13 bankruptcy which
is a payment plan on your debts for five
years well the first thing you do is you
build up a thousand dollars do you have
any debts that are not in the bankruptcy
if you do you pay those first and then
if not you put your chapter 13 as your
only debt snowball item and you're gonna
save up and pay it off in one fell swoop
working with the chapter 13 trustee not
your lawyer call the chapter 13 trustees
office 98% of chapter 13 trustees do a
great job they're one of the few bright
spots in the whole bankruptcy system and
so go in there and work with them
they'll either allow you depending on
your district to pay extra payments like
it was just a bet but get it out of
there get it paid off inside of the five
years lump sum or extra payments either
one is fine and you've got to be on a
budget and you've got to be in attack
mode it's not yet as you've noticed the
debt didn't go away when you put it in
chapter 13 chapter 13 says payments
that's exactly right now you're still
you're still paddling and the water you
know that you're still you know the
canoes going this way but the waterfalls
still coming up behind you it really is
a daiva oftentimes in these bankruptcies
people will reaffirm on vehicles yeah
and and so that's you agreeing to to
either try to catch up on the vehicle or
keep it and so it's just one of those
chances where you know you
got to use this as a moment of reset
well her family didn't go down on her
vehicle secured dad and I chapter 13
she's paying the full payment where she
gave up the car and she didn't give up
the car no and so you know the only
thing that could have gone down will
been some of these other payments on the
unsecured stuff that and it goes down
either because they've reduced the total
debt and if that's the case then we can
still pay it off in the debt snowball
you typically advise people to let the
car go in a chapter 7 always in a
chapter 13 I there's very few times I
put somebody in a chapter 13
right because it's just paying payments
and that's what you're gonna do you're
already paying pay that's right and so
I'd rather you work something I would
have sold the car yes and avoided the 13
that's the way it probably would have
been if you'd come to us ahead of time
with coaching but she's already there
and we'll help you kiddo where you are I
understand how scared you are you can
hear it in your voice I remember that
feeling and you're going through a year
of financial peace as our gift and then
you get to call us back someday and yell
your debt free this is the Dave Ramsey
show